with the latest figures from the  Department of Health these are on the  number of cases and the middle being  tested but also said so number of  fatalities as of 1 p.m.  422 deaths now recorded from coronavirus  that is a total number of tests of  82,000 359 which were negative just a  fraction over 8,000 positive 90,000  tested as of 9 a.m. on the 24th of March  settlers in the context reaching you as  well about 17 deaths in Wales 16 sorry  now 17 in Scotland and 3 in Northern  Ireland but as the the essential  arithmetic from these latest figures is  that in the space of 24 hours number of  deaths from coronavirus in the UK has  risen from 339 to 422 a rise of in  excess of 80 in a 24 hour long period